this is Al Jazeera I'm daddy and Abigail
we're bringing you continuous coverage
of the UK's prime minister's Boris
Johnson's resignation after two days of
political high drama Johnson has
announced his resignation so the Prime
Minister made a statement outside his
official residence in Downing Street
just about half an hour ago and he said
he was sad to be leaving the best job in
the world Boris Johnson had been
resisting the calls for him to step down
here's what he had to say
it is clearly now the will of the
Parliamentary conservative party that
there should be a new leader of that
party and therefore a new prime minister
and I've agreed with sigraine Brady the
chairman of our back bench MPS that the
process of choosing that new leader
should begin now and the timetable will
be announced next week and I've today
appointed a cabinet to serve as I will
until a new leader is in place so I want
to say to the millions of people who
voted for us in 2019 many of them voting
conservative for the first time thank
you for that incredible mandate the
biggest conservative majority since 1987
the biggest share of the vote since
1979.
and the reason I have fought so hard in
the last few days to continue to deliver
that mandate in person was not just
because I wanted to do so but because I
felt it was my job
my duty my obligation to you to continue
to do what we promised in 2019
and of course I'm immensely proud of the
achievements of this government from
getting brexit done to settling our
relations uh with the continent for over
half a century reclaiming the power for
this country to make its own laws in
Parliament getting us all through the
pandemic delivering the fastest vaccine
rollout in Europe the fastest exit from
Lockdown and in the last few months
leading the West in standing up to
Putin's aggression in Ukraine
and let me say no to the people of
Ukraine that I know that we in the UK
will continue to back your fight for
freedom for as long as it takes and at
the same time in this country we've been
pushing forward a vast program of
investment in infrastructure and skills
and Technology the biggest in a century
because if I have one insight into human
beings it is the genius and talent and
enthusiasm and Imagination are evenly
distributed throughout the population
but opportunity is not and that's why we
must keep leveling up keep unleashing
the potential of every part of the
United Kingdom and if we can do that in
this country we will be the most
prosperous in Europe
and in the last few days I've tried to
persuade my colleagues that it would be
eccentric to change governments when
we're delivering so much and when we
have such a vast mandate and when we're
actually only a handful of points behind
in the polls even in midterm after quite
a few months of pretty Relentless
sledging and when
the economic scene is so difficult
domestically and internationally and I
regret and not to have been successful
in those arguments and of course it's
painful and not to be able to see
through so many ideas and projects
myself but as we've seen at Westminster
the herd instinct is powerful when the
herd moves it moves and my friends in
politics no one is remotely
indispensable and our brilliant and
darwinian system will produce another
leader equally committed to taking this
country forward through tough times not
just helping families to get through it
but changing and improving the way we do
things cutting burdens on businesses and
families and yes cutting taxes because
that is the way to generate the growth
and the income we need to pay for great
Public Services
and to that new leader I say whoever he
or she may be I say I will give you as
much support as I can
and to you the British public
I know that there will be many people
who are relieved
and uh perhaps quite a few who will also
be disappointed
and I want you to know how sad I am to
be giving up the best job in the world
that thems the breaks
I want to thank Carrie and our children
to all members of my family who've had
to put up with so much for so long I
want to thank the Peerless British civil
service for all the help and support
that you have given our police our
emergency services and of course our
fantastic NHS who at critical moment
helped to extend my own period in office
as well as our armed services and our
agencies that are so admired around the
world
and our indefatigable conservative party
members and supporters whose selfless
campaigning makes our democracy possible
I want to thank the wonderful staff here
at Checkers uh Tahira number 10 and of
course at Checkers and our fantastic
prop Force detectives the one group by
the way who never leak
above all I want to thank
you the British public
for the immense privilege that you have
given me
and I want you to know that from now on
until the new prime minister is in place
your interests will be served
and the government of the country
will be carried on
being prime minister
is an education in itself
I've traveled to every part of the
United Kingdom and in addition to the
beauty of our natural world I found so
many people possessed of such boundless
British originality and so willing to
tackle old problems in new ways that I
know that even if things can sometimes
seem dark now
our future together is golden so that
was a statement Johnson made just a
short time ago Let's cross over to
Westminster and bring in Rory Charles
he's joining us from there so how is
this going down at Westminster Rory
because he's resigned but he's staying
on for a little bit and presumably
conservative MPS will have a reaction
and so will the opposition
um yeah it depends on who you talk to
there are certainly MPS in Westminster
who would like to see the back of Boris
Johnson as soon as possible and there
are others uh who would like the process
uh to work itself through and to maybe
take a little bit more time uh over it
now Boris Johnson in his resignation uh
address there said Dems the brakes that
it was the kind of uh the Brilliance and
darwinian system as he put it I think
really that he feels did him in uh now I
can speak to uh Stuart Andrew who until
yesterday was uh housing minister
you know Boris Johnson was it the system
that did him in or was it Boris Johnson
himself well I think probably a
combination of the two really but you
know I'm not going to knock the man when
he's down I've I had to make a difficult
decision but I recognized he's done an
enormous amount of work as prime
minister not least the brexit situation
we found ourselves in
um responding quickly uh to the pandemic
and of course the issues that we're
seeing in Ukraine
um but ultimately you know people were
racing with me about trust and integrity
and so I had to make that decision to go
yesterday then you said the country
deserves better why did you say that
well because I think actually you know
people need to politicians get a bad
name anyway we don't want to confirm
that and I think it's important that we
have people in place that people can
trust and and that's what I want to see
restored but now is a time for this
position to happen that the leadership
election happened and we can carefully
consider who the next leader of the
party should be so you don't agree then
with Andrew bridge and I was speaking to
him earlier and he was saying that Boris
Johnson needs to go right now that
they're about more damaging allegations
to come out about him and that he is
fatally compromised he needs to go right
now well it's the normal run of things
when the Prime Minister stands down that
they do continue until the new leader
has been elected that happened with
David Cameron it happened with Theresa
May
um and you know we need to get the
functioning of government up and running
again quickly because there are some
serious issues that need addressing let
that process happen so that we can get
on with running the country well we
spoke about an hour ago and you were
running off to go and do something in in
Parliament tell us what you were running
off to do and why so um as the housing
Minister I was with my colleague Neil
O'Brien taking through the leveling up
and regeneration bill which is in
committee at the moment of course we
both stood down yesterday and so there
isn't a minister at the moment to see
that bill go through so as a consequence
we had to meet this morning just to
adjourn the committee until next week
when probably somebody will be in post
because that's a big problem isn't it
there is at the moment uh barely a
functioning government so I mean the
thing is we mustn't forget that there
are thousands of civil servants in this
in the system that do an incredible job
and so they will be making sure that
that processes still happen but you're
right in terms of you know the process
of delivering the legislation in here
that is slightly in in flux at the
moment but I'm pretty confident that
that'll be restored fairly you know
pretty quickly and but certainly by next
week who do you want to see is the next
leader so I haven't made my decision yet
I'm Keen to hear what the candidates
have got to offer because there are some
really big challenges facing the country
not least cost of living and people
concerned about that and seeing you know
the prices rising inflation is is a
concern to people and also how we
respond continue to respond in the
situation in Ukraine so I want to listen
carefully to what the candidates are
have to say and see what their vision is
for the country but also how they want
to lead us into the next election so
that we can hopefully win that again
there are big problems facing the
conservative party aren't they the the
recent by-election defeats point to a
fracturing of the conservative party's
electoral Coalition that you're perhaps
losing the red wall that you gained most
recently in the north and perhaps losing
a blue wall in the South as well so how
does uh the next leader of the party
rally that disintegration and try and
prevent a a defeat at the next election
so you know I've been in this game long
enough now to know that actually
by-election's midterm for any government
whatever color are incredibly difficult
and I don't think it's insurmountable to
to get ourselves back and ready with a
serious chance of winning at the next
election but I would certainly hope that
the new leader will certainly focus on
those issues that people do care about
and I think to do that you know leveling
up is something that I think is
resonating in communities that have been
left behind for so many decades so I
think that will help us in the red wall
areas but equally making sure that the
cost of living crisis is being addressed
for people all over the country and
recognizing the conservative values that
people do support you know cutting taxes
and being sensible running the economy
so those are the sorts of things we need
to focus on from now on in because the
latest polls aren't particularly good
for the Tories are they it suggests that
uh
the the general population is is moving
against the party so the thing with the
with the balls is that they do keep
changing a lot now I have to say you
know I remember when Margaret Thatcher
was in government and she would often be
20 points behind and she often would
argue that if she wasn't mid-term she
was doing something wrong so you know
and she went on to win elections and I
think that has happened you know in
other scenarios since so I'm I'm I think
we can get this back we've just got to
focus we've got to unite now behind
whoever is the new leader and we have to
speak directly to the people of this
country that we are serious about
addressing their concerns so what about
the timetable then for for uh replacing
Boris Johnson how quickly should this
move well that'll be for the 1922
executive to set the timetable I suspect
although I could be wrong that we will
probably have quite an accelerated
um Camp you know sort of process within
the weeks before recess so that
hopefully then we can have the two
candidates who will go before the party
membership and they have summer recess
to sort of go around the country to
speak to members of the party you know
who ultimately will make that decision
brilliant thank you very much to Andrew
thank you sue Andrew who formerly was a
housing Minister back to you thank you
so much Rory challenge reporting from
Westminster
so with Boris Johnson's exit who are The
Front Runners to take over the top job
well there's a former Chancellor Richie
sunax had a high profile in the pandemic
he gained popularity as the public face
of the government's economic recovery
plans but concerns over his wife's tax
status were costly there's the foreign
secretary Liz truss who is one of the
most popular senior members of the party
her previous post of international trade
secretary saw her secure post-brexit
trade deals also in the running former
foreign and health secretary Jeremy Hunt
who was Boris Johnson's main rival in
the last leadership contest saja Javed
has now resigned twice from Boris
Johnson cabinets first as Chancellor
then on Tuesday he quit as health
secretary Javed was the first person of
color to hold one of the great offices
of States when he was appointed Home
Secretary in 2018. Nadeem zawahi was
immediately named the sunax replacement
as Chancellor he previously served as
education secretary Let's cross over to
Paul Brennan who is joining us more from
London to talk about the the potential
candidates going forward Paul and
actually what happens next
well that's a big question because the
timetable has not exactly been specified
we heard from Boris Johnson in his
speech at the lectern over my shoulder
uh well less than an hour ago now just
to say that a timetable will be
established next week in order to
finalize exactly how the transition of
power will be organized but there are
many people who do not want Boris
Johnson to remain in charge uh even As a
caretaker prime minister while the
process continues many MPS many former
ministers many people who resigned from
the government because precisely of
Boris Johnson I think it would be an
absolute mistake to have him in charge
that he's the reason why they went and
they don't think he should stay some of
the quotes were really quite brutal I
mean um Dominic Cummings the former
special advisor to Boris Johnson here at
Downing streets who became Johnson's
Nemesis after Cummings left down the
street said leaving Johnson
risk Carnage another former Minister
unnamed said the behavior of Boris
Johnson over the previous 48 Hours was
Reckless and erratic and he can't be
trusted through to the Autumn um God
knows what he will do uh and another one
um was that George Freeman a minister
who resigned this morning before Boris
Johnson finally capitulated and said
that he was going to step aside um said
that Johnson needs to hand in the seals
of office to the queen and advise her to
call for a caretaker prime minister to
take over from today so there is a lot
of pressure for Boris Johnson not to be
allowed to remain in Downing Street for
a period of perhaps as long as three
months uh holding Court over this kind
of caretaker Administration through to
the Autumn when a new leader would
attack well the intention is to have a
new leader elected for the conservative
party in time for the Autumn conference
um many people deeply unhappy about that
and it's still very uncertain as to what
the timetable will actually be Paul let
me ask you something about the
opposition Kirsten leader of the main
opposition party said this that he would
call for a parliamentary confidence vote
in the government if the conservatives
did not remove Johnson at once How
likely is that still to happen
there's a lot of questions about what
the labor party strategy is going to be
I don't want to
turn off our International viewers by
getting into the sort of inside baseball
of British domestic politics but I mean
there's a lot of a lot of questions
being asked about Labor as to why
they weren't pushing for a confidence
vote in Parliament you know selecting a
prime minister is essentially a
conservative party almost internal
process it's not a wider country that
selects the Prime Minister it's the
conservative party in Parliament their
MPS get together they decide which of
them is good enough for the top job
which of them has the support to take
the top job
um it's not for the wider parliamentary
uh
well contingent that said when Boris
Johnson was digging his heels in and
refusing to go uh and the prospect was
that the internal processes of the
conservative party would not be quick
enough in order to remove him and might
be next week a lot of pressure was on
the labor party to say well you labor
party you call a vote in Parliament
because there's probably a lot of
conservative and peaceful side with you
and and get rid of Boris Johnson
um a lot of questions as to why that
wasn't and I think one reason why was
because the labor party were concerned
that if they were the ones who were seen
to wield the knife against the Prime
Minister it might actually coalesce
support around him you know as Boris
Johnson said in his departure speech
here the herd instinct is strong and an
attack on a prime minister even as
flawed as Boris Johnson might just bring
support back into his uh into his Camp
so I think that's why Labor's strategy
has been on the one having a hand
perhaps quite subtle perhaps quite
clever but on the other hand still opens
a question all right and just one more
you poll I mean what does this all mean
for the governance and the running of
the country list trust has come out with
a statements calling for calmness and
unity but but in terms of the governance
and the issues that people are really
dealing with the High Cost of Living
inflation what impact is is this going
to have
well it is going to have an impact I
mean there is some mirth uh in
Westminster circles about Liz truss's
predicament she is the foreign secretary
she is in Bali at uh in Indonesia uh the
G20 Summit and yet her Ambitions for the
conservative party leadership and the
Ambitions of her to be prime minister
are well known so it is a stroke of
unique bad luck for her to be
essentially on the other side of the
world when all this is going on so she
is understood to be racing back to
Britain as quickly as she possibly can
to put herself into the mix of all of
this as far as the processes of
government go well Boris Johnson this
morning started reappointing ministers
to the officers of state in order to try
to maintain some kind of functioning
process some kind of functioning
government for the weeks ahead we've got
about two weeks left before Parliament
is due to rise for the summer holiday so
there's not long actually for government
to to continue but there are always
decisions that are necessary even in
even in the holiday periods so even
though Parliament is is rising on the
21st of July the actual departments
treasury defense they still need to
operate and without it without ministers
to to sign off on decisions to actually
make decisions it's very difficult so he
has been making appointments this
morning
The Dilemma is who's going to take those
appointments and how can they operate I
mean many of these people actually quit
because of Johnson and if he's staying
in number 10 it is a really difficult
conundrum for people to Circle for them
to square if they're going back into a
government which still has him even
normally at the head of it okay thank
you so much Paul Brennan reporting from
London let's bring in our political
commentator Jonathan list he's joining
us by Skype from London as well welcome
to Al Jazeera so um Paul Brennan was
just saying that uh even though Boris
Johnson has obviously resigned he's
staying on for a little while longer
he's still making some appointments some
cabinet appointments what is the
strategy behind that
the strategy is to inflate his ego as
much as it could possibly go
um he's determined to cling on to office
cling on to his title as long as his
party allows him and now that makes no
sense the country which is facing you
know incredible challenges in the cost
of living crisis also of course from the
Ukraine war and it doesn't make any
sense
um for the party either which needs to
elect a new leader so it can try and
rebuild some of the damage that Johnson
has done now there is no reason why uh
Johnson needs three months even if he
was going to stay on As a caretaker
which he shouldn't by the way but even
if he was going to stay on three months
is is far longer than he needs or the
conservative party needs to elect a new
leader Theresa May became prime minister
I think 19 days after David Cameron
resigned as party leader Johnson himself
became prime minister a month and a half
after Theresa May resigned as party
leader this does not need to stretch out
to October
so how do you see the next couple of
weeks then playing out or what would you
what would you like to see because
clearly uh you are against the the
process that is currently taking place
right now we have a deputy prime
minister Dominic Robb who is you know
I'm no fan of him politically but he is
the Deputy Prime Minister and that role
exists for precisely this purpose taking
on the mantle of prime minister when the
Prime Minister becomes been disposed now
Johnson has clearly accepted that he's
not going to be prime minister anymore
and he's lost uh the the faith the trust
the Goodwill of his party as well as the
country it makes no sense for Dominic
rather not to take on uh this caretaker
role uh for which his his title uh
equips him
um when Johnson doesn't enjoy the
confidence if all these ministers have
told Johnson that he's not there to
serve it makes no sense for them to then
decide to serve for three months three
months is three months too long what did
you make of his statement in general
because
um a lot of people pointing out that
um that he didn't seem to apologize for
anything
[Music]
but Johnson has never really apologized
sincerely to anything in his life so I
wouldn't expect any genuine Contrition
from him it was actually quite
extraordinary uh the some of the things
he was saying and he talked about he
stayed on through a sense of Duty that
was the last thing he was thinking about
he just wants to stay on because he
enjoys being prime minister and he wants
to stay on a few months longer as well
because he wants to Outlast the tenure
of Theresa May because he thinks it
would be humiliating to be prime
minister for less time than she was but
he also said really bizarre things about
resetting our relationship with the EU
while he's about to bring on a trade war
with our closest political and
Commercial friends and also talking
nonsense about lockdown of the vaccine
rollout which has been completely
forgotten in terms of the vaccine
rollout by the British people the bottom
line is that Boris Johnson really has
very few achievements to speak of the
one thing he's done getting brexit done
first of all hasn't actually happened
because we're still fighting with the EU
but even if it was done it's a complete
disaster that Britain's economy there's
nothing at all to boast about all right
we'll have to leave it there thank you
so much Jonathan list for speaking to us
from London
so Boris Johnson has often made divisive
and controversial decisions during his
times the UK's prime minister Jonah Hall
has more on that
don't vote for us he led his party to a
landslide election victory in 2019 but
Boris Johnson was to be undone both by
events in which he conspired and also by
his own character flaws that critics say
made him unfit for high office boss
Johnson has no social Vision he has
there isn't no moral leadership but for
him it was always about becoming prime
minister not about being prime minister
and he I think he knows himself well
enough that he knows that he does not
have the skills that you need to be a
successful prime minister
Sonia Purnell was a reporter working
alongside Johnson in the Brussels Bureau
of the Daily Telegraph she describes a
man with a lot of the child in him who
enjoyed getting into and out of scrapes
a man drawn to chaos and the chaos means
that he can sort of emerge through all
these things going wrong all these all
this noise all this commotion as the
person with the great idea or the wit
the witticism and and that is what
appeals to him
for Boris Johnson the coronavirus
pandemic was a perfect storm of crises
and Chaos that blew attention away from
other problems
despite his promise to get brexit done
Britain remains mired in dispute with
its biggest trading partner the European
Union
the economy is underperforming the cost
of living Rising health and education
systems faltering
success with the vaccine program helped
obscure Johnson's own indecision and
delays in following scientific advice
that contributed to one of the highest
death tolls in the developed World
former Chief adviser Dominic Cummings
described the prime minister's
leadership as erratic indecisive
distracted nobody
could find a way around the problem of
the Prime Minister just like a shopping
trolley smashing from one side of the
island to the other
the shopping trolley metaphor would
quickly be seized upon by the opposition
so he's doing what he always does
crashing over to the other side of the
aisle Boris Johnson learned early to be
self-sufficient in a family of
competitive siblings with a mother who
suffered ill health and a father who was
frequently absent at the elite British
boarding school Eaton he came to believe
ordinary rules did not apply to him in
the infamous Bullington drinking Club at
Oxford the outward Persona of a jovial
buffoon disguised an inner ambition for
power and as both a journalist for the
Times newspaper and a minister in
opposition Johnson was accused of lying
and fired these then were the qualities
he brought to Politics as mayor of
London as foreign secretary and then as
prime minister entitlement dishonesty
and indifference this is really the
first time in his life where he's ever
actually been held to account for
anything he's always been indulged he's
always been excused there's always been
reasons made for him for his bad
behavior there was wide support for his
handling of the war in Ukraine but
Johnson never recovered from the Scandal
known as partygate he received a police
fine for attending a lockdown party in
Downing Street making him the first
British Prime Minister to break the law
while in office a civil service report
into a string of similar Gatherings
described a failure of leadership
eventually 148 of his own MPS 40 percent
of the Parliamentary party turned
against him in a vote of no confidence
Boris Johnson limped on for a bit
but the reasons to forgive him had run
out
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera
let's bring in Tim Bell who's a
professor of politics at Queen Mary
University of London he's joining us
from there welcome to Al Jazeera so is
it the right thing for Boris Johnson to
do to stay on as caretaker
I think that is a really difficult
question uh clearly most of the public
who want to see him resigned uh uh would
like him out straight away I think it's
something like seven out of ten people
think he should go and go now
um those MPS who resigned from the
government will clearly feel that he
should go now and let the Deputy Prime
Minister take over the role of the
caretaker prime minister is simply to
keep and ship afloat and uh not to make
any particularly controversial
statements or policies is Boris Johnson
really the man to do that I don't think
so right because we've already seen him
make some cabinet appointments earlier
on today even though Boris Johnson as
you know has resigned himself so what do
you think the strategy is behind that
well I mean he has post to Phil he
doesn't want to bring in the people who
resigned uh most of those people he has
brought in would be recognized generally
speaking as allies of his or else people
who are just willing to do the job for
the sake of
um Public Service I don't think there's
any uh sense in which he's you know
making a move to try and stay on
um but I think you know one of the
things that he does care about is how
long he will be prime minister for he
does want to beat Theresa May's record
of staying in office that's that's clear
and he doesn't want to depart the scene
immediately he wants a little bit of
time perhaps even to make up for the
chaos that he's caused over the last few
days and I think he does very much value
his relationship with Vladimir zielinsky
uh in Ukraine he'd like to see himself
carrying on that kind of world Statesman
role uh and I suggest that that's
probably something to do with it what is
your sense of how the the leadership
election will pan out in terms terms of
the the key candidate it's going forward
well I
resignation really
um
started this process that Sergeant Javed
and arushi Suna will definitely stand
there are a couple of people who stayed
in cabinet in order to demonstrate their
loyalty thinking that that would enhance
their appeal Liz truss is certainly one
of those Ben Wallace the defense
secretary maybe another people have
talked about a more Junior Minister
Penny Waters and there are also people
outside of the government who could
argue that it's best to go for a Clean
Skin somebody who's not associated with
Boris Johnson someone like Tom tugenhart
who heads up a foreign affairs committee
uh also Jeremy Hunt who lost to Boris
Johnson back in 2019. so there are a
whole range of people who will stand and
we could see as we did in 2019 actually
around five uh uh votes of the
Parliamentary party in order to winnow
down uh the number of MPS who go forward
to the membership ballot to just two
people so I think we'll see a pretty
chaotic process over the next few days
in which people will suggest themselves
as candidates test the waters and then
we will get almost straight away into
the voting right and and just give me
your sense of how damaging
um you think this could be for the party
or has been for the party in fact
well that's a good question I mean
there's no doubt that Boris Johnson's
personal ratings have been appalling for
quite some time and they have probably
been dragging the conservative party
down I I suppose there is some optimism
within the conservative party that once
they ditch him people will begin to look
at the party and the government and you
that that is possible but you have to
count that off against the fact that
this country is facing some pretty dire
economic circumstances we have a huge
spike in inflation possibly we are going
in to recession uh whether you know
Boris Johnson goal will make much
difference to that certainly if you
believe Tim Bell I'll just have to jump
in there my apologies but we're coming
to the end of the program but thank you
so much for joining us and speaking to
us from London